so we wanted to uh we wanted to go in
and just have a guest from the uk that
we could talk to he's
fresh off his first ufc bout and
uh and and it was a win and we got jack
shore
entering right here probably wouldn't
have him on if he lost let's be real
about it
okay
[Laughter]
and he's also a massive king in the
sting fan yeah that's true he loves the
show
let's see if we can get him i think
jack can you hear us yeah monica
what's up man what's going on not much
dude just want to say congrats on your
win
man and uh and just let you know we're
doing an episode that's all british
and um and we just wanted to talk to
somebody from britain and see how it's
going over there
yeah well i appreciate the the thanks on
the win britain's a bit
uh but crazy at the minute we're still
like locked down big time so
you know we're uh we come i come back
from the fight island i'm straight back
from the house so uh
i'm getting i'm getting a little bit fat
i can't get as much training as i want
but oh brilliant fat
[Laughter]
yeah i'm all good i'm all good i'm uh
i'm getting back into the
the fake boy status again already got my
bike you know
i was i was too skinny to uh to be
classed as a fit boy i think on the
fight night
no you're in the club bro do they give
you uh do you get tickets out there like
we do in america like i got a ticket for
riding my bike outside when the pandemic
first hit
uh we haven't had i haven't heard enough
in you know they're not so strict i mean
there was a rule that you couldn't you
couldn't leave the house uh favor then
sort of
five to ten kilometers but no one really
listened i think
running on the bikes and [ __ ] yeah yeah
we
i haven't had a ticket yet i mean i i'm
trying to get away from him as fast as i
can but
you know it's a little bit different for
you on the trails i'm on the roads a
little bit so i try and uh
avoid the police if we can are are all
the pubs shut down there those are bars
not allowed yeah it's it's completely
shut they've opened like um
outdoor areas now in the in the pubs and
the clubs but
i cut a couple of couple of landlords
and i
that i know have opened up on the sneak
and they've been shut down like real
fast so
we still uh there's no one there's no
one drinking legally at the minute over
here but there's a lot of people
drinking illegally
and do um ask him something
are you an oasis fan yeah massive voices
that's my favorite band hey how do you
so if joshua and fury fight how do you
guys decide whether who the [ __ ] the
root for
i think it's quite 50 50. um to be
honest like
the last year with fury and he's sort of
coming back from
the mental elephant coming back from
obviously he was down and out
he's just the public loves him over here
now like going back five years ago
everyone ate the types of fury now all
of a sudden
he's this this like you know the general
public to see him as this superstar this
hero so
i mean i'm team gypsy king all the way
but uh
you know joshua is people are fond of
joshua over here too so i i think it's
really going to be like a 50 50 split
but
uh i'm i'm team gypsy taking out the
doubt
me too and what about when you guys had
that guy that fought logan paul
what were you guys yeah ksi does anybody
cheer for that guy
or did did everybody think that they
were both a bunch of wankers or what was
the deal
for him now you got like get knocked
about ninny pretty easily but um
you know i don't even think like that
anyone took that fight seriously
[Laughter]
it's more of an american thing yeah
now the rematch was my uh second date
with my girlfriend or my first date with
my girlfriend i brought to the staples
center for logan paul ksi oh you did
the undercard was billy joe saunders
who's english stud and like
no one gave a [ __ ] about the real fights
like in full of youtubers
yeah it was 12 year olds with their
parents it was it was hilarious
i think he would jack would say billy
joe saunders is legit billy joe saunders
yeah supposed to fight canelo until he
did some stupid video
pretend to hit a woman on a bag damn
yeah billy
billy joe's um a little bit
controversial
he doesn't help himself sometimes like
like you said the video with the women
and
he's always like instagram line winding
up sorry instagram live like winding up
homeless people and
he's funny though he's tyson fury's best
friend oh yeah
he's a character now was it pretty cool
at the yaz island or was it kind of like
scary or what was it like yeah it was
pretty cool i mean we didn't see as much
as it was
as we would have liked we was like
locked in the hotel room for you know a
couple of days and then by the time we
we had the weigh-ins and the fight i
mean i thought 4am and i was
flown back home 4pm the next day so we
didn't get to see too much of it you
know but uh
we're just just grateful to be out there
with the team and you know we're able to
fight and
earn some money in uh in these crazy
times was it weird fighting with no
crowd
yeah a little bit i mean it was the the
walk out and the the inflows with bruce
buffer it was really weird like
it seems awkward like there's like jack
shaw and it was just dead silence
but uh the fight itself wasn't too bad i
switched off from it a little bit so
you know it was just a walk out that was
a little bit weird but i want to shout
out them
i think chappelle liked it i don't know
if he's seen it but he's seen i walked
out to an oasis too
gang man legit oasis dude
i gotta get out there man what am i
doing we gotta ship you over there man
yeah well look
one of the things we wanted to say jack
is that we might be coming back to uh
our original homeland to the uk because
things are getting a little bit weird
over here dicey over here
we might fire up the old mayflower and
head on back
we need to read some tips do you think
yeah what are some tips that you could
give us that's a good question where
should we go should we go should we land
in liverpool
manchester stroud you don't want to land
in liverpool trust me on that one
darren till says they have the best
nightlife in all
in all of england man odds
yeah if you're like if you like fighting
and
getting pushed around a lot like they
crazy at the liverpool yeah it's like
west county huh
yeah but if you're coming to the uk stop
off in wales yeah we're only small but
then we show you a good time we're uh
we're very welcoming down here so come
down to the to the small part and uh you
know we'll always be welcome
we pick whales over england every day
and what are some things that uh we
should know like
how to adapt into the culture there
because i mean there's a there's
probably about a 12
chance that we're actually going to come
to come and i'd say even 12
is pretty high there's probably a 99
chance with me yeah so yeah what are
some what are some things we could do
especially chappelle even to adapt into
the culture
like chappelle's having heard of wine
gums
oh wine gums are the best the best
porsche weigh-in treat everyone
get that sugar straight in the system
[Laughter]
the biggest tip man obviously if you
come over don't drive on the right-hand
side of the road
all right that's a good start i think
that's a good start
i didn't want to put him on the spot but
uh i asked him before the show did you
have any uh
english uh debate clubs or kingdom or
stingers for the guys
you want to throw out to them yeah you
want to throw one out jack before we uh
before we let you go here and thanks so
much for uh for joining us this morning
man
yeah no problem um it's not so much an
english one but
that i know uh obviously brendan used to
be in the ufc and i know field's a big
fan um
of dustin pouring the guys so debate
club for me would be
having fought in in obviously with fans
present and then in an empty arena
would you rather the fights with the
fans or without the fans
um i don't know sometimes those fans are
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so
it's like
they give stupid ass advice like rip his
head off
i'm [ __ ] trying i'm really good dude
you know so i found the ultimate fighter
with no fans it was kind of dope
less pressure you can just do your thing
feels like practice
i don't mind i like watching without
fans too so i don't mind no fans man
yeah and i probably would get my ass
kicked in either space so
i uh i think i would say no fancy
because i don't want anybody there to
see it you know
you know i'm yelling world star
then you can hear dan hardy out the ref
with no fans that's true that's always
fun
yeah um who was the ref for your fight
jack
it was actually herb dean who dan had to
run in with so
yeah he's uh he's probably not fond of
us british at the minute because of
daddy
he'll be all right who do you think are
winning a fight out of herb dean and no
nonsense keith peterson my idol
is keith peterson been drinking or no
i'm gonna go out on a limb is keith lit
what are we doing man i'm gonna say i'm
gonna go on a limb and say yes
um keep beating the center and every day
yeah all day bro
jack thanks so much for uh jumping on
man and we appreciate it
and uh and we hope to see you soon in
your country we'll be showing up on the
show
yeah yeah welcome anytime thanks for
having me on guys i'm a big fan
thanks brother
[Music]
is